heute reden wir über sichere ende
nämlich über sterben und tod
hast du eigentlich angst vor dem sterben
ich habe schreckliche angst vor dem
sterben aber nicht nur von den stärken
irgendwie auch vor toten körpern
vergleichen also es geht mir ja geben
mir irgendwie ähnlich und ich denke
damit sind wir nicht allein und heute
wollen wir herausfinden warum das so ist
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der tod tanzt uns auf der nase herum
manchmal können wir seinen besuch
hinauszögern doch wir wissen es er kommt
wieder
trotz aller kunst der medizin früher
sterben die menschen jung und rasch am
häufigsten an hunger krieg oder
infektionskrankheiten
heute ist das sterben geprägt von
chronischen krankheiten
es kann wochen oder monate dauern
der plötzliche tod trifft nur etwa zehn
prozent der menschen häufig werden noch
aufwendige behandlungen vorgenommen um
den tod hinaus zu zögern tritt er dann
doch ein wird das oft als ein versagen
der medizin wahrgenommen
zuweilen sehen wir den tod aber auch
dabei
die meisten menschen in der schweiz
knapp drei viertel sterben im heim oder
im spital
manchmal begleitet von erfahrener
palliativpflege und den liebsten
manchmal allein was braucht es für ein
gutes sterben und was passiert im moment
des todes der sterbe moment selber
bleibt ein mysterium
[Musik]
lange zeit bestimmten staat und kirche
der rituale um sterben und tod
bisweilen wurden die toten aufgebahrt
meist jedoch schaffte man sich schnell
weg zur kreation oder ihre bestattung
heute wird ein bewusster abschied der
angehörigen von den sterblichen
überresten ihrer lieben immer wichtiger
leichenbestatter rinnen und bestatter
richten verstorbene liebevoll her und
sorgen dafür dass die natürliche
zersetzung unsichtbar und geruchsfrei
bleibt der vorgang der zersetzung eines
leichnams ist ein tabu
warum erfüllt uns die verwesung von
ehemals lebendige mit grauen und epe und
wovor fürchten wir uns wenn wir uns vor
dem sterben fürchten ja herzlich
willkommen zur sternstunde der nacht und
auch ihnen hier im saal im kaufleuten
ganz herzlich willkommen
ja heute widmen wir uns also einem
tabuthema sterben tote körper leichen
und bei mir sitzt jemand für den ist das
alles überhaupt kein tabu mark benecke
ist der weltweit bekannteste
kriminalbiologe untersucht insekten auf
toten körpern und kriminalfälle
aufzuklären schrieb zahlreiche
bestseller ist gastdozent in der ganzen
welt und experte in fernsehserien wie
etwa medical detectives herr benecke
wenn ich persönlich eine leiche sehe
dann beschleicht mich ein ungutes gefühl
etwas zwischen ekel und angst
wie ist das bei ihnen ja für uns im
beruf wird als kriminalbiologen ist das
ja ein spurenträger die leiche also es
ist eher etwas was wir spannend und
interessant finden im kriminalistischen
bereich also da sind dann halt haare
drauf oder hautzellen sperma blut
insekten sowas und als biologe sehen
will natürlich nur dass die stoffe die
da drin sind fette und eiweiße und so
dass die wiederverwertet werden oder
auch das eisen im blut ist es ja auf der
erde noch nie eisen entstanden dann also
wir atmen ja nur weil wir immer wieder
dass eisen wieder verwenden was die
ganze zeit von anderen lebewesen stein
und wasser pilzen bäumen verbraucht und
dann wieder freigegeben wird also es ist
der kreislauf des lebens weil es klingt
das würden sie über ein objekt reden
nicht über einen toten menschen ja wo
ich also wenden wenn man tot ist ist man
ja nicht mit der die persönlichkeit du
kannst ja keine witze machen mein
musikgeschmack ist weg das ist ja alles
nicht mehr da was dich mal ausgemacht
hat seine mimik oder gestik insofern
gegenstand würde ich nicht nennen aber
es ist halt halt der körper den man mal
hatte der körper an sich bleibt ja auch
nicht immer gleich
also es ist ja so dass wir wissen was
wir trinken was es geht energie rein da
geht es wieder raus durch schweiß oder
hitze oder ich weiß nicht turin und so
also wir sind ja nur so kann man das
sagen so eine art energie geister also
nur dein körper ist ja morgen oder
übermorgen auch anders als er jetzt ist
es ist ja nichts ist ja nicht so als ob
jetzt einen körper hass der dann am ende
auf einmal sich auflöst da spricht der
biologe biologischen prozesse aber diese
faszination für den toten körper für den
toner für das sterben woher kommt das
bei ihnen
ich habe ja ich mag das lebende also ich
sehe da nur das leben drin also als
biologe ist das sterben ja gar keinen
das gibt's ja gar nicht also es ist ja
wie schon sagt ja einfach nur
wiederverwendung das ist dass der stoffe
die die vorher drin war und wir fragen
uns als biologen oder lernt der mensch
stirbt doch ja die persönlichkeit stirbt
aber gut da kann es ja auch noch spuren
hinterlassen also deine sendung
vielleicht erinnern sich noch in 100
jahren die leute da ich meine dass das
was du tust und denkst und bewirkt oder
vielleicht auch nur eine einzige tat
oder so die sind ja noch da also selbst
das vergeht ja gar nicht sie haben sogar
den schädel von adolf hitler habe ich
gelesen untersucht ja ich musste etwas
macht das mit einem gefühlsmäßig ich
fand das sehr interessant also das war
ja insofern spannend weil eben einem
archiv lagen die zähne und in einem
anderen archiv lag dass schädel stück
ein schädel stück mit einer ausschuss
öffnung und die frage war hat er sich
vergiftet oder ist erschossen worden
und dann wieder woanders lagen erhalte
akten dann gab es auch röntgenbilder bei
geheimdiensten aus der zeit als er
gelebt hat also das war ist so einem
jahr ein puzzlespiel um rauszukriegen
was halt wirklich passiert ist und was
damit zusammenhängt und was nicht und
natürlich manche leute kommen auch immer
noch einen frack lebt ja immer noch und
so was das kann man dann auch
beantworten
ich habe in der vorbereitung über einen
satz gestolpert von ihnen nehme ich den
satz was ich schreiben man stirbt
biologisch gesehen schon ab dem 24 oder
25 lebensjahr
das heißt wir beide befinden uns schon
in den sterbeprozess ja oder sagen wir
so wir die die aufbau vorgänge sind
nicht mehr so schnell wie die abbau
vorgänger sagen wir mal freundlich
genau das ist richtig also es ist halt
so dass das dieses erblühen des körpers
der anwachsen und die fertigstellung
die sind irgendwann abgeschlossen und
danach geht es dann sehr sehr sehr
langsam in die richtung des abbaus
genommen das ist richtig
sie sind ja bekannt dafür weltweit dass
sie insekten auflebenden körpern
untersuchen ich habe das gesagt auf die
toten eher entschuldigung auf kraft und
leben
ja manchmal darauf leben dann aber
meistens eher auf tod genau nämlich auf
toten körpern sind solche ekligen das
sind ihm eigentlich täglich die lappen
ich finde die larven von schmeißfliegen
oder jetzt richtig gestellt die mal da
hin dass in diesem wissen besser zieht
vielleicht kann sie etwas darüber
erzählen kommen dem was irgendwie
fernsehen die interessant um einen
kriminalfall zum beispiel aufzupolieren
kriminalfällen sind sie spannend weil
man daran dass die liegezeit einer
leiche feststellen kann also sagen du
bist jetzt mehr wald gebracht oder
irgendwo wo es warm genug ist so dass da
auch insekten eier ablegen können das
sind diese erwachsenen blauen oder grün
schillernden fliegen die so brummer oder
die heißt den reeder region anders ne
also schmeißfliegen und die legen eier
ab und diese pakete entwickelt sich dann
auf der leiche als jedem ei schlüpfen
einem adel und da die geschwindigkeit
des marktwachstums abhängig von der
temperatur ist kannst jetzt ausrechnen
wie lange die leiche besiedelt
das ist manchmal spannend zum beispiel
sagen wir du hast überhaupt gar keine
ahnung wer das ist du kannst nichts mehr
erkennen alles ist verfault aber dann
hast du zumindest ein anhaltspunkt okay
es muss jemand sein der vielleicht vor
einem monat oder vor einem jahr oder vor
einer woche in den wald da gelangt ist
was kommt das sonst noch für tiere
diese laufen ja du hast aaskäfer nennt
man diese umgangssprachlich manche
versuchen sonst und mäuse zu begraben da
gibt es aber auch welche die dann in der
leiche so gut kann man bauen die dann
manchmal auch die schussverletzungen auf
es gibt unendlich viele tiere also es
gibt ich würde mal sagen hunderte von
tierarten die irgendetwas je nach
zersetzung stadium von der leiche
mitnehmen es gibt zum beispiel wenn die
leiche breiig käsig zerläuft so heißt
hast dann danach sollte käse fliegen
drauf die auf alten käse stehen
das ist keine menschlichen leichen von
denen sie noch ich rede von mensch ja
klar das macht keinen unterschied ob das
jetzt eine tierisch wurde eine
menschliche leiche ist das ist dasselbe
hier im studio das anbauen bereiten sie
forschen nach so an beiden ja genau es
gibt länder da kannst du menschliche
leichen raus legen zum beispiel in den
usa da gibt es ein gelände wo das geht
in deutschland wenn wir jetzt mit
studierenden arbeiten im wald kleine
leichen oder in england nehmen wir als
irgendetwas was vom tierarzt sozusagen
eine freigegeben wird also wieder etwas
aus der tiefkühltruhe was gibt tiere die
halt dann irgendwas verstorben sind
krebs oder irgend alter sozusagen multi
organ versagen
dann legen wir die raus aber besser ist
es natürlich mit menschen gleichen zu
arbeiten weil die tiere keine hände und
finger und füße und seen haben genau und
sie haben das auch gemacht mehrmals etwa
vor 20 jahren diese erfahrung in den usa
auf einer sogenannten body farm und was
das ist das schauen wir uns ganz kurz an
nichts für zartbesaitete
hinter dieser manns hohen zaun in
knoxville tennessee liegen dutzende von
leichen
seit mehr als 30 jahren wird hier die
verwesung von menschen studiert vom
ersten tag bis zur vollständigen
skeletten
die einheimischen nennen diesen wald der
leichen schlicht und einfach body farm
[Musik]
2002 wollte benecke zu studienzwecken
auf der body farm
damals inszenierte sich der junge
forscher noch ganz als angehender
sherlock holmes auf der body farm werden
verschiedenste möglichkeiten bei der
verwesung nachgestellt hier kann man
innerhalb kurzer zeit sehr viel über
sonderfälle lernen und kann das dann auf
fälle die offen sind oder die in zukunft
noch kommen anwenden
es werden ausschließlich leichen von
menschen untersucht die zu lebzeiten
ihren körper der wissenschaft vermacht
haben diese leiche war teilweise der
sonne ausgesetzt das gewebe ist daher
leder artig ausgetrocknet was zu einem
besonderen fress muss da führt
unter berücksichtigung von klima und
andere natur einflüssen kann benecke nun
rückschlüsse ziehen wie lange die leiche
schon liegt
der wald der leiche ein einzigartiger
friedhofen dienst der wissenschaft
ja herr benecke wenn ich das nur schon
sehe wird mir übel ist diese sherlock
holmes pfeife auch deswegen um diese
gerüchte wie nicht zu zu richten so gar
nicht ich habe früher einfach pfeife
geraucht also früher war der umgang mit
der gleichen auch noch nicht so starke
geregelt also wir haben noch an ganz
andere experimente gemacht mit strang
marken und so also das hat sich im laufe
der jahre alt ein bisschen verändert
weil immer kleinere spuren gesichert
werden konnten zwar stellte einzelne
hautschuppen und deswegen haben wir
jetzt immer mehr schutzanzüge mehr
handschuhe an und so aber das früher war
es üblich also als new york früher
gearbeitet habe hat der chef auch noch
im tweet anzug an den leichen gestanden
ohne handschuhe also da war ich noch
dabei also und was sind die wichtigsten
einsichten die man gewonnen hat das
diesen body fahrens verschiedene sachen
also das eine ist dass du überhaupt
nachstellen kann ist wie sich der leiche
in einem kofferraum in einem see unter
beton und so weiter verhält also dass
man nicht sagen kann
meiner erfahrung nach müsste die leiche
jetzt seit zwei wochen einbetoniert sein
sondern dass man mal harte daten hat das
ist sehr gut dann viele so also märchen
maden kriechen eine bestimmte richtungen
und dann musst du dort nach ihnen suchen
weil die nach der nachdem sich
vollgefressen haben halt witzig
verpuppen und dann irgendwo verstecken
und dann möchte man diese kleinen uhren
diese kleinen leichten regen ja auch
finden aber da gibt es dann im märchen
darüber dass konnte man da sehr schönen
testen weil es da gefälle gibt wenn man
konnte wasser lang laufen lassen
also ich war gut vorbereitet als ich
dann die mumie palermo angeguckt habe da
sind wir den größten boom im keller der
welt gewesen und wussten schon mal grob
welche tiere wo an welcher stelle sein
werden
es ist einfach ein tolles
trainingsgelände aber diese idee dass
unsere körper wenn jetzt begraben werden
in einem sagt dass die von firmen
gefressen werden sagen sie das ist ein
mythos dass ja würmer sowieso nicht also
außer du nennst die larven würmer aber
man kann die unterscheiden also die die
larven von insekten werden später
irgendwas mit flügeln und beinen und
firma bleiben immer für ein ganzes leben
lang also in der erde hat sie vielleicht
regenwürmer
aber da musst du schon wie wir das in
der einleitung gesagt das schon ganz zu
erde geworden sein damit die regenwürmer
sich dafür interessieren ansonsten
normale firma mögen keine leiche
sie sind ja mit dem was sie machen
extrem erfolgreich und sehr berühmt ist
ein bestseller ich habe es gesagt haben
eigenen podcast im eigenen youtube kanal
leben sie in gewisser weise auch von
diesem tabubruch von diesem gruseleffekt
von dieser angst angst lust die viele
leute haben naja also der der podcast
der seit 20 jahren läuft ja ich habe
öffentlich rechtlichen das heißt er wird
also kommissar youtube channel wird
überhaupt nicht bezahlt also ich glaube
ich dass man davon leben könnte weiß ich
also ich mache jedenfalls nicht also ich
krieg dafür nichts aber wenn man schaut
was sie sonst noch machen sie sind zum
beispiel vorsitzender einer dracula
gesellschaft er der einzige seite
überwand ihre sie nach landesvorsitzende
einer partei namens die partei das sind
aus doch ein bisschen bisschen unseriöse
zumindest meint aus der schweiz
verhältnisse viel initiative gesagt das
beeinträchtigt aber nicht ihren ihren
ruf als seriöser wissenschaftler oder ja
also ich meine es ist ja eine
wissenschaft so dass du du
veröffentlichst ja etwas was andere sich
angeschaut haben das nennt man peer
review also die kollegen und kolleginnen
schon vorher drüber sonst wird es ja gar
nicht veröffentlicht und insofern ist es
eigentlich ziemlich egal ob die jetzt
bier wasser oder wein trinkt privat oder
auch bei einem kongress es geht ja um
die messbare leistung das ist ja der
große vorteil wie auch bei der body farm
du kannst dir gemessen und es geht eben
nicht mehr um glauben meinen hoffen
soziale einschätzung kulturelle
einschätzung deswegen also seriös ist
das was du anhand von daten beweisen
kannst wasser und wer wäre nix hat wer
keine daten hat der ist halt ein
quatschkopf
das ist interessant weil über das was
macht dem tod kommt da gibt es ja keine
daten
was ist denn ihr verhältnis ihr
persönliches zum stärken zum zum tod
also ich finde da gibt es ja viele daten
ich sehe die ganze zeit leute die
verwesen also nicht mal das ernst also
da gibt es eigentlich hätte eigentlich
das genau bekannt was dann passiert also
du hast wohl mit dem körper mit dem
körper ja genau
du warst es sonst noch gibt ja das weiß
ich also das weiß ich nichts darüber ich
weiß du meinst jetzt irgendwie eine
seele die in den äther wandert oder so
ich habe das kann man kann ich nicht
messen dazu kann ich nichts sagen also
da war habe ich keine informationen
haben sie eine vorstellung davon was mit
ihrem körper passieren sorgen nachdem
sie verstorben sind ja ich denke ihr
also ich finde das sollten die
angehörigen lieber entscheiden oder wenn
man das vorher mit den angehörigen schon
geredet hat dann freuen sie sich also
timothy leary zum beispiel hat gesagt
ich möchte meine asche soll in den
weltraum geschossen werden und da hab
ich gesagt ja das passt zu dem gut aber
ich mache ja die eigene gleiche
eigentlich für eine bodyform zur
verfügung stellen das wäre irgendwie
indianer body farm verso im
kriminalistischen zusammenhang nach dem
tod will ich dann nichts mehr von
verbrechen hören dass ich das lieber
nicht wirkt ja aber du hast mir recht
hat er dieses der der kreislauf des
lebens also dass die stoffe aus denen
der körper besteht wieder zurück in den
kreislauf gehen ohne jetzt verbrannt zu
werden das ist eine riesen energie und
stoff verschwendung
das fände ich natürlich schon gut aber
andererseits wenn ihr angehörigen das
dann gruselig finden oder was du vorhin
gesagt dass die vorstellung nicht magst
und du wirst jetzt mein bruder oder so
dann halt sagen lassen weil das ich will
ja nicht dass du dass die lebenden sich
google vielleicht zum schluss noch eine
letzte frage zu ihren tattoos sie haben
ja ganz viele tattoos und dachten händen
vielleicht können sie das mal zeigen was
man da lesen kann holt fast das ist aus
der seefahrt kunst festhalten
aber der tod sterben hat ja glaube ich
viel mit dem loslassen zu tun
warum steht dass da würde ich auch sagen
genau das ist nur so seemann statur aber
es stimmt beim beim sterben oder vor dem
sterben aber eigentlich beim leben muss
irgendwie halt alles mögliche loslassen
ich war mir irgendwann sind eine kinder
erwachsen und dann kannst du dir auch
nicht mehr mit ihrem kinderzimmer
einsperren oder keine ahnung der
lieblings gegenstand steht der jetzt im
weg oder der riesige
schallplattensammlung ist größer als
sein wohnzimmer oder sowas da musste das
halt mal gehen lassen dass
so ist das schon aber ich denke das hat
dem tod nicht so viel zu tun sondern
menschen glauben dass immer und denken
ganz am ende kommt dann der ganz große
knall das endgültige aber ich denke das
ganze leben besteht eben aus wie ich das
wort schon schilderte es geht etwas rein
in dich und es geht doch raus in dich
und deswegen ist es gut mal festzuhalten
wenn man überzeugt ist dass man es
festhalten soll aber genauso wie ein
seil am segelschiff muss das halt
irgendwann loslassen sonst funktioniert
das mit dem segeln auch nicht mehr
der kreisel haft des lebens habe ich
erst mal vielen dank für das gespräch
wir werden sie am ende der sendung noch
mal hören auf dem sofa bei meiner
kollegin herzlichen dank ich habe zu
sagen herzlich willkommen ich freue mich
dass sie hier sind
sie sind notfall psychologe sie waren
sehr sehr lange bestatter und sind heute
auch technologie also wissenschaftler
für sterben und tod
und ich würde gerne mit ihnen zuerst
darüber sprechen was herr becker gesagt
hat nämlich über diese faszination wenn
es um das tot sein wenn es um leichen
geht
teilen sie diese faszination ja der ist
hier ich habe mich auch in meiner
dissertation im rahmen des
psychologiestudiums sehr intensiv mit
dem sogenannten leichen tabu befasst ich
habe gleichen berufe befürchte bestatter
menschen in anatolien pathologie und
habe so die frage gestellt wurde
geschaut was macht der tote körper mit
ihnen also diese strahlkraft der leiche
also dieses eben wirksam werden können
der leichen tabu
das war so ein haupt
forschungsschwerpunkt in dieser
forschung sammeln
und was glauben sie warum haben denn die
meisten doch angst vergleichen sie ja
nicht aber die nicht das will ich nicht
sagen ich bin in manchen nächten auch
nicht an eine bei uns durch den kühlraum
gegangen und in manchen nächten soll
also die angst also dass dieses dieses
die menschheit dürfte irgendwann einmal
den leichnam mit einem tabu belegt haben
und das tabu ist der etwas was eine
kraft eine macht ausstrahlt die sich
massiv unterscheidet von gewöhnlichen
also so wie wir heute hier zu gebrauchen
wenn wir sagen ja der tod ist ein tabu
hat er nichts mit dem tabu begriff an
sich zu tun wir ursprünglich im
politischen gemeint war
denn ein tabu würde bedeuten ein echtes
tabu wenn ich ein tabu
dann zieht das eine strafe nach sich die
auch ende psychisch sofort spürbar wird
und das zeichnet sich zum beispiel im
leichten trab manchmal so ab ich mache
ja viele seminare mit berufsgruppen die
immer mit damit verstorbene umgehen
müssen und dass sie zum beispiel sagen
trotzdem ich handschuhe tragen wenn wir
mit einem verstorbenen umgehen habe ich
nachher trotzdem so das bedürfnis ich
möchte mir ein paar mal mehr die hände
desinfizieren oder dass die
dienstkleidung wechsel und manche
menschen haben schnell das gefühl als
würde ihnen jetzt etwas an haft oder es
gibt in der allgemeinen vorstellung auch
so mythen wie das gleichen gift oder
diese dinge also ist alles anbieten
das sind weitgehend mythen ich weiß
nicht was der herr professor weniger
dazu sagt aber die allgemeine
vorstellung beim laichen tabu wie adidas
sowie der tod eingetreten ist jetzt in
dem körper sofort stoffe entstehen die
für uns lebende sofort irgendwie
gefährlich werden können und dass vieles
davon ist einfach nicht so
wissenschaftlich gesehen
mich interessiert aber trotzdem das tabu
auch noch in dieser vielleicht eher
lebensweltlichen bedeutung wir sprechen
ja auch oft davon dass das sterben oder
der tod in unserer gesellschaft ein tabu
sei und oft wird dann gesagt man hat den
tod gegen die aus der gesellschaft
verband früher gab es das totenglöcklein
das geklungen hat wenn jemand verstorben
ist oder man hat die toten aufgebahrt
man hat den sack durchs dorf getragen
heute ist das alles nicht mehr so
gleichzeitig denke ich mal sprechen wir
doch unglaublich viel über den tod es
gibt heute patientenverfügungen wir
sprechen über suizid beihilfe
der tod ist doch eigentlich recht
präsent ja das würde ich auch so sehen
also diese rede von der verdrängung des
todes das kann man auch kritisch
betrachten also es könnte auch eine
logische folge unserer zivilisation
stufe sein wie wir das heute ändern
die verklärung der früheren zeit ist
auch etwas mit dem ich mich auch in
meinem buch sehr beschäftigt habe das
schaut glaube ich nur von außen so aus
also sie können viele omas und opas
befragen
der leichnam ist auch im volksglauben
oder das leichentuch hat gerade im
volksglauben hochkonjunktur gehabt die
zeit vom eintritt des todes bis zur
bestattung die sogenannte schleusen zeit
dieses prekäre zwischen stadion
da ist der verstorbene zwar tot aber
immer auch noch irgendwie hier und er
kann auch vielleicht um gut werden
und viele dieser rituale die es damals
gab
hatten auch den sinn in einem
psychologischen oder spirituellen auch
den sie sich vor den toten körper
vielleicht auch ein stück weit zu
distanzieren um den verstorbenen auch
nicht zu erzürnen
ich mache im jahr ungefähr mit 2.000
menschen diese seminare und bearbeiten
oder schauen uns diese diese dinge an
die im volksglauben da waren und das ist
erstaunlich was gerade im ländlichen
raum in österreich und in teilen
deutschlands dann noch vorhanden ist
sie bieten ja auch so genannte letzte
hilfe kurse an
ja genau was müssen wir denn da lernen
oder wobei brauchen wir hilfe weil
gestorben wird ja ohnehin ja ja nein
hilfe gibt's da kenne ich helfen aber es
geht mir im letzten hilfe kurs geht es
um drei wesentliche säulen also die eine
wesentliche säule ist diese betrachtung
des leichten tabus das müssen wir
unbedingt kennenlernen denn so verstehen
wir auch erst warum wir mit dem tod
umgehen wie wir umgehen und jede kultur
wie jede kultur mit dem tod umgeht wie
sie umgeht über dieses leichten tabu
lernen wir auch diese anthropologische
konstante in uns kennen die die
todesangst bis dass er todesangst ist
sozusagen in uns eingeschrieben in der
biologie schon das geht und selbst der
haltung und diesel turbo ist wichtig
weil dieses leichen tabu auch ganz
massiv unsere abschieds kultur
beeinflusst und da sind wir bei einer
zweiten ebene das letzte hilfe kurs ist
wir schauen uns an wie wichtig ist
vielleicht für hinterbliebene sein kann
sich noch einmal weiblich von einem
verstorbenen zu verabschieden
es kann für manche betroffene sehr
wichtig sein den verstorbenen vater die
verstorbene mutter oder das kind noch
einmal zu sehen und noch einmal berühren
zu können
vielleicht ganz unmittelbar vor dem
begräbnis einen letzten blick zu haben
und da schauen wir uns im letzte hilfe
kurs an was wir als mitmenschen da
füreinander tun können
wir können da für die betroffenen ein
sogenanntes hilfs ich sein und den
betroffenen hier zur selbstbestimmung
verhelfen
denn es ist nicht usus dass die
betroffenen zum beispiel von den
bestattern dazu eingeladen werden und
ich treffe viel zu viele menschen die zu
mir sagen was ich hätte meinen vater
noch mal sehen können das hat mir
niemand gesagt das schauen wir uns an
und dann noch als dritte säule die
herausforderungen der begegnung mit
betroffenen mit menschen
es ist eine große herausforderung für
uns auf mitmenschen zu treffen wo etwas
passiert ist
arbeitskollegen oder mann verstorben ist
jetzt umgehen mit dem was sagen was tun
das sind die drei säulen das letzte
hilfe kurses dh der letzte hilfe kurs
dient wirklich nur dazu denjenigen zu
helfen die mit dem tod konfrontiert sind
einer anderen person das eigene sterben
irgendwie lernen das kann man nicht
das wusste ich nicht wie das geht denn
den tod ist der etwas was wir nie
erfahren können wahrscheinlich und jetzt
wüsste ich nicht wie wir üben was man
nicht erfahren habe ich kann er auch es
gibt zb palliativmedizin als schon
domenico borasio der hat ein buch
geschrieben über das sterben und der
spricht davon dass wir ja
interessanterweise viele
geburtsvorbereitungskurse selbst die
männer machen dass mittlerweile dass man
dann auch egal wie gut vorbereitet ist
was da alles auf einen zukommt
und vielleicht ist es hilfreich genau zu
wissen wie das sterben abläuft um diese
prozesse irgendwie besser verstehen zu
können und sie vielleicht auch darauf
einlassen zu können
ja aber da bin ich nicht kompetent und
ersten stirbt nicht jeder sozusagen
sterben dem sinne von ich habe jetzt
eine erkrankung und gehe auf den tod
hinzu ich als bestatter weise dass viele
menschen ganz anders die haben der
plötzliche herztod der verkehrsunfall
sonstige dinge dass suizid dann lassen
die meisten kamen wahrscheinlich das ist
schwierig
also ich verstehe das ansehen und die
palliativ ist da oder die hospizbewegung
leisten daher wunderbares
nichtsdestotrotz gilt es für mich in der
auseinandersetzung ich schreibe gerade
einen neuen buch wo wir uns mit dieser
tiefen und 17 todesangst befassen
die wir so nicht schneller anerkennen
die meisten leute hier werden sagen ich
habe doch keine todesangst ich habe
angst davor zu sterben im sinn von wie
sterbe ich im sinn von vielleicht sehr
schmerzhaft das will ich nicht arbeite
vor dem tod habe ich keine angst
und wenn wir genauer schauen das system
körper sagt uns etwas anderes
und wir können auch beobachten was wir
sozusagen psychologisch tun müssen um
diese todesangst in den griff zu
bekommen
ich würde gerne von ihnen wissen das ja
auch bestatter sind wie würden sie denn
gerne mal als leiche aussehen
möglichst alt und möglich nachhaltig ich
habe deswegen weil man ja leichen auch
sehr schön herrichten kann das ist zum
beispiel dann ein thema vor allem dann
ein thema wenn eine leiche eben schon
lange verwaist ist oder wenn es ein
verkehrsunfall gab ein gewaltverbrechen
damit die verwandten noch abschied
nehmen können ohne sich irgendwie zu
erschrecken
und jemand der das macht gleichen so
herzurichten ist die christine per loch
nass ist philosophin und auch
bestatterin und sie war vor ein paar
jahren bei mir zu gast und haben sie
mitgebracht die ganz zum einsatz kommen
wenn man davon ausgehen kann dass es
dann abschied am offenen markt gibt wo
die angehörigen noch einmal zu uns
kommen um sich vom verstorbenen zu
verabschieden
dann schau mal dass es keine
geruchsbildung gibt und das vermeidet
man durch ganz einfache maßnahme man
dann abonniert die körperöffnungen mit
watte aus denen gerüche austreten
könnten das heißt es wird über die nase
ramponiert in den rachen und über den
mund in den rachen
man macht dann da einen tropfen über der
speiseröhre und der luftröhre dann kann
nichts austreten aus dem morgen und aus
der lunge und dann natürlich der after
über den after also in den enddarm wird
auch warte eingeführt bzw in die scheide
der frau und so kann man diese ersten
leichen gerüche oder eventuell
austretende flüssigkeiten
oder ausscheidungen kann man stoppen was
sind apps und und was ist das hier
ok also das auge verliert sehr schnell
an flüssigkeit fällt dann zurück und
dann hält das augenlid nimmer das ist
das was man sieht im krimi oder die wenn
man eine leiche darstellt dann hat ihm
auch seine augen er aber bei dort die
augen im krimi meistens nur in einem
relativ guten zustand
beim verstorbenen ist es oft schon so
dass am zweiten oder dritten tag das
ganze irgendwie sehr darüber wird und
einfalt man da heute das augenlid
einfach niemand da gibt es dann diese
möglichkeit man setzt ein icon das ist
im prinzip eine kontaktlinse mit
widerhaken
das ist ein einbaum harz man gibt dann
ein bisschen baumharz dann noch drauf
das schlägt mit wir superkleber aber das
ist eine haftcreme und besetzt man dann
aufs auge auf also so und tätern das
augenlid drüber
und die gibt es natürlich in
verschiedenen größen und mit
verschiedenen volumen und dann kriegt
man einerseits wieder das volumen vom
auge her und andererseits bekommt man
schon einen beschluss herzliche art und
weise leichen herzurichten behagt ihnen
nicht behagt mir so eigentlich nicht
also die weigerung anzuerkennen dass wir
tiere sind und fleischliche körper die
sterben werden ist ja die grundlage für
wahrscheinlich für eine sehr starke
emotion nämlich der emotion des ekels
und diese vorgehensweise bedeutet für
mich ja auch so zu sagen es ist er hat
ja etwas leicht aggressiv ist auch
sozusagen so massiv in den körper
einzudringen und ich war ja selbst lange
bestatter und viele menschen haben sich
am offenen sarg verabschiedet und diese
massiven eingriffe wurden nicht
vorgenommen ich weiß schon dass es
vielleicht manche verstorbene geben kann
wo das so massiv ist aber ich habe mal
zu einem kleinen kurs mit bestatter
kollegen besucht und da haben alle
sozusagen einhellig gesagt sie würden
das büro man nicht machen
jetzt sagen sie würden das nicht machen
aber sie haben ja schon noch massivere
kritik sie sagen wo in einem text
das sei eine art verpflichtung des todes
als schweizerin nicht dass ein rössli
eine verpflichtung des todes und damit
sagen sie so was wie man verniedlicht
eigentlich das tot sein man macht es
schöner als es ist und trägt dann zu
einer re tabuisierung des todes bei das
müssen sie erklären
diese tendenz kann man durchaus ein
bisschen beobachten das ist sozusagen
diese verpflichtung ist entstanden in
einem gespräch aber man kann sehr
schnell beobachten schon in der sprache
und in der bildsprache in diesen trauer
bereichen so zu sagen dass man hier sehr
schnell in richtung ja welchen engel
blümchen blätter wie sie kommt auch in
der sprache sozusagen auch die sprache
der trauer hat der trauerbegleitung hat
dürfte etwas weich gezeichnete und auch
natürlich in diesem oft in diesen
sterbebegleiter bereichen kann man das
dort oder da beobachten von einem freund
von mir ist der vater verstorben
ein 86 jähriger landwirt im ländlichen
raum und ist in grand dort ländlichen
krankenhaus verstorben und man hat den
schon angerufen er kann kommen der vaart
ist versteuerung sie haben eh schon
gewartet und dort gab es auch ein
bisschen eine hospizversorgung und also
hin gekommen ist war der vater tradiert
und zugedeckt mit bunten seidentüchern
mit papier schmetterlingen tüftel ein
lämpchen und dergleichen und das hat
natürlich mal in diesem fall nicht
stimmig aber dass wenn ich damit ein
bisschen das kann man durchaus ein wenig
beobachten und für mich bedeutet das
eine tabuisierung deswegen weil ich auf
den eindruck habe nur so darf darüber
gesprochen werden oder nur so darf die
bildsprache sein und das hat auch etwas
von einem tabu also nur so darf es sein
aber vielleicht auch wenn ich sie
richtig verstehe so was wie anerkennen
tot sein ist schmerz ist verlesung ist
auch tier sein ist rapper sein und das
ist auch natur und die ihnen wichtig das
anders so lässt dass man so lässt und
wir wir müssen als menschheit das
anerkennen versuchen auch psychologisch
anzuerkennen versuchen solange wir
weltbilder und sonstige orientierungs
überzeugungen und zulegen werden wir
auch immer konflikte haben
zwischen den gesellschaften und kulturen
also das wäre sozusagen der weg also
diese forderung die menschen müssen sich
doch mit dem tod beschäftigen das greift
viel zu kurz wenn es geht um das
kennenlernen dieser innen und tief
sitzende angst der wir nicht so schnell
bei kommen und diese forderung bedeutet
ja oft ja gibt ich halt dreien ist ja
nicht so schlimm so sehe ich das
überhaupt nicht es ist jedes es ist
jeden sein recht auch nicht sterben zu
wollen es ist auch jeden angehörige es
jetzt von jedem angehörigen das recht
nicht zu wollen also ein vater und ein
kind verstirbt und vor allem wenn wir
das zeichnen denken wir immer an
vielleicht den alten oder lang kranken
und sich damit arrangieren verstärkenden
aber wir müssen immer bedenken viele
menschen stehen wir auch ganz anders
ja die grausamkeit des todes gilt es
auch zu anerkennen dürfen zu können
danke ihnen sehr herzlich für diese
erste einschätzung gleich nachher noch
einmal dankbar
hier sitzt jetzt sabine mehne sie ist
vor 25 jahren an leukämie erkrankt stand
mit einem bein schon im jenseits könnte
man sagen leidet heute an chronischen
spätfolgen und bereitet sich auf ihr
sterben vor kann man sagen termine
lange war es unklar ob sie überhaupt
heute an dieser sendung teilnehmen
können wie geht es ihnen denn ich bin
zufrieden weil ich gelernt habe dass man
auch mit wenig viel viel erreichen oder
ein gutes leben führen kann das ist
immer eine frage der perspektive
als ich für mich als wichtig oder
unwichtig beachte ich fragen was das für
spätfolgen programm leiten sie heute
also es gibt etliche spätfolgen in
meinem damen am herzen ich habe zum
beispiel eine neuropathie als ich fühle
den boden nicht mehr so dass ich eben
mit dem stock laufe weil ich angst habe
zu stürzen
und ich habe
dieses chronische fertig syndrom also
ich vergleiche das immer mit einer
luftmatratze die ganz viele löcher hat
man kann die löcher zu kleben aber im
lauf der zeit gehen auch die
klebestellen wieder auf also man pumpt
immer wieder rein uns mag sie sind oft
zu gemüte heißt es von der idee genau
und ich musste schon auch mühsam lernen
damit zu leben man kriegt nichts umsonst
trotzdem möchten sie keine medizinischen
behandlungen mehr in anspruch nehmen
hier warum nicht also ich habe so viel
hochleistungsmedizin bekommen und das
war für mich auch wirklich eine sehr
sehr schwere zeit
also man denkt immer medizin ist leicht
oder toll natürliches sie toll aber sie
ist auch sehr gewaltig sehr brutal sehr
schmerzhaft und wirklich sehr sehr sehr
unschön das muss man auch mal zugeben
aber muss auch zugeben dass sie ohne
medizin heute nicht hier so richtig ohne
medizin würde ich nicht hier sitzen aber
auch noch vor 70 jahren gab es diese
methoden ja noch gar nicht also das ist
auch etwas ganz neues die medizin solche
fortschritte gemacht hat vor 70 jahren
hätte ich gar keine chance gehabt und in
einem anderen land der welt hätte ich
auch keine chance gehabt und ich habe
einfach gelernt auch zufrieden zu sein
mit dem was ich habe und was für mich
ganz schlecht es ist stress und in einem
krankenhaus zu sein ist immer stress
und deswegen möchte ich an diese orte
nicht mehr gehen
sie möchten haben sie mir gesagt zuhause
rumliegen inhalt sterben richte meine
ruhe haben und in meinem eigenen bett
sterben und sie sind befürworterin des
sterbe fastens gleich müssen sie uns
sagen was das ist wie wir uns genauer
das vorstellen müssen wie lange das
dauert
was man nimmt dann keine nahrung mehr zu
sich also dass der begriff sterbe fasten
ist eigentlich falsch weil dann denkt
man man muss nur aufhören zu essen aber
mit wenig essen und trinken kann man
sehr sehr lange leben das haben wir ja
auch im krieg gesehen
die menschen hatten wir nicht zu essen
und waren aber topfit
das entscheidende ist dass man dies die
flüssigkeit einstellt also dass man
irgendwann dann auch so gut wie gar
nichts mehr zu sich nimmt 20 milliliter
sind erlaubt für die mundpflege und dann
die linie neben kaputt und letztendlich
steht man an einem herzstillstand als
aber das ist unterschiedlich also es
gibt fälle die haben es in fünf tagen
geschafft es gibt fälle die brauchen
drei wochen und andere die braucht und
vielleicht sogar zwei monate und ich
denke das hängt auch damit zusammen
man weiß ja nicht ob die leute wirklich
so ehrlich sind und nicht mehr trinken
also das trinken die flüssigkeit ist das
entscheidende und schmerzmittel nehmen
sie gar keine oder dann in dieser phase
des sterbens ostens nimmt man da gar
keine schmerzmittel zu sich das kommt
drauf an das muss man immer ganz
individuell sehen also ich bin zum
beispiel sehr dankbar dass ich jetzt
seit april bekomme ich das medizinische
cannabis das mit thc an versehene und
cbd und das hätte ich nicht für möglich
gehalten dass mir das noch mal so gut
geholfen hat ich habe wirklich viele
jahre sehr viele schmerzen erduldet und
war schon sehr verzagt und das ist ein
gutes medikament was sehr gut den
menschen unterstützt und damit geht es
mir sogar im moment wieder ein bisschen
besser da bin ich sehr froh
weil wenn man sich auf das sterben
vorbereitet dann heißt das ja nicht dass
man keine lust mehr zu leben
also ich lebe ja wirklich auch sehr
gerne und ich sage immer jeden abend
wenn ich ins bett gehe
heute ist wieder ein tag wo ich nicht
gestorben bin also dieses bewusstsein
für das was wir haben oder nicht haben
das ist glaube ich der entscheidende
punkt es ist schon eine unglaubliche
lebensfreude auch haus muss sich sorgen
trotzdem bereiten sie sich jetzt schon
auf der sterben vorjahr zwar ganz
konkret vielleicht haben sie
konzertieren ziemlich lang mit einem
partner zusammen genau das heißt diese
ablöse prozess dieser langsame also ich
hab jetzt vor drei jahren habe ich damit
angefangen mich damit auseinander zu
setzen ich muss vielleicht dazu sagen
dass ich in meinem ganzen leben immer
schon bestimmte sogenannte ich nenne es
mal vorahnungen hatte also es gab immer
bestimmte dinge in meinem leben wo ich
genau wusste das ist es
es war bei meiner berufswahl so es war
wie ich meinen mann kennengelernt habe
es war ein absoluter zufall und ich
wusste der ist es es war so wenn ich
schwanger war wusste ich schon immer
bevor ich den test gemacht habe dass ich
ein kind bekommen und und und so ging es
immer durch mein leben so wusste ich
auch 95
als die ärzte die diagnose nicht stellen
konnten wusste ich diese krankheit hat
den tod im gepäck und ich bin froh dass
ich diesen vorahnung ernst genommen habe
und mich schon damals darauf vorbereitet
habt dass es vielleicht nicht gut
ausgehen könnte weil es mir sehr viel
mehr geholfen hat auch das kranksein zu
ertragen
und so war es jetzt vor 2017 wieder
wir haben einen sechzigsten geburtstag
gefeiert mit einem wunderschönen fest
und wir kommen nach hause und wunsch
kommt da wieder diese vorahnung
und da ich gelernt habe sie dich zu
ignorieren sondern darauf zu hören habe
ich sie ernst genommen und habe gefragt
gefühlt und sodann habe ich so bestimmte
vorgehensweisen wie ich das überprüfen
und dann habe ich gesagt okay ich
bereite mich jetzt darauf vor
dann habe ich alles geregelt wenn es
anders kommt das ist ja auch gut also
schauen wir mal aber alle
habe ich dann schon geregelt und meine
wichtigste meine wichtigste mein
wichtigster wunsch ist wirklich dass ich
keine medizin mehr habe ich möchte
einfach nicht mehr das an mir herum
hantiert wird ich schlucke keinen schlaf
mehr
das war vor drei jahren die sie
entwarnung ist aber könnte es jetzt noch
sein dass sie noch 15 20 jahre leben wo
er wisse ja wenn ich noch 15 oder 20
jahre leben will dann muss ich jetzt
wieder reparaturmaßnahmen machen lassen
also das herz muss operiert werden
der darm muss operiert werden das muss
ich dann schon tun aber das möchte ich
nicht mehr
mir reicht das einleben was ich habe und
ich bin damit zufrieden und schauen sie
ich rechne immer doppelt eigentlich bin
ich nämlich schon 88
weil ich jedes jahr seit ich
transplantat bin doppelt gezählt und es
müssen nicht alle 90 werden und ich
möchte auch nicht 90 werden sie
bezeichnen sich selbst aussterbe
künstler worin besteht die kunst
ich glaube meine meine kunst besteht
darin also wenn ich mich vielleicht mit
einem malerin vergleiche dass sich ein
anderes bild versuche vom tod zu
zeichnen
also wir haben einfach auf blöde
vorstellungen im kopf über den tod und
das sterben und für mich war der tod
immer ein guter freund und er war
wochenlang monatelang jahre lang an
meiner seite und ich habe mich mit ihm
arrangiert also ich habe auch keine
angst vor dem sterben
ich freue mich sogar auf diesen moment
wenn ich es dann geschafft hab mein
eines buch heißt der große abflug also
ich denke ich fliege dann und ich lege
dann nur den körper ab also ich bin zu
gast hier auf diesem planeten und ich
habe diese ausrüstung dafür bekommen und
wenn meine zeit vorbei ist dann lege ich
diesen körper ab und vielleicht auch die
frage sie haben sich wahrscheinlich
überlegt was mit ihrem körper passieren
soll wenn sie nicht mehr da sind also
genau ich habe besprochen mit meiner
familie und mit allen menschen die mir
dann er
werden ich habe das schon ganz schön
vorbereitet dass ich möglichst in ruhe
gelassen werden will
also ich möchte dass die stille ist mir
das kostbarste und ich habe zum beispiel
die idee dass sich möglicherweise in der
seite sterbe oder mit man mir dann hilft
auf die seite zu legen und dann habe ich
zur bestatterin gesagt ja dann könntet
ihr mich eigentlich auch so in den sarg
legen warum muss man immer auf dem
rücken so liegen also auf die welt im
mutterleib sind wir auch zusammengerollt
warum nicht auch am ende und wenn es
anders kommt kommt es anders es ist aber
wenn ich so darüber nachdenke finde ich
das eine schöne vorstellung ich habe
auch gesagt ihr braucht nicht so viel
herum zu waschen wenn ich nicht
verstehen gepackt mich in eine decke und
lasst mich bitte einfach in frieden
setzt euch zu mir und einfach nur die
stille genießen ich finde wir haben so
viel stress beim auf die welt kommen und
dann gehen das müssten wir ein bisschen
ändern frage erst mal vier und
herzlichen dank für dieses offene
gespräch
[Applaus]
die bigcitybeats sie überlegen auf 20
euro das sind die momente wenn jemand
vergisst thema glüht tauber gesagt bevor
das ist nervös es stimmt wir vergessen
das heißt es muss schon machen wir mit
der zeit des dürener mit deiner geburt
und eine todesfälle unter daten und so
gott sowie home sowie go zum go und zum
coach von al qosi schlichtes nicht dass
es dort von toten
das ergebnis beide trotzdem ist es oft
verschwendet zu fescher demokratisches
sie rutscht sie leben und dort stärker
aus oder selber vornimmt oder vater ist
gestorben über zweiter grétry druck kam
vom früheren statement experimentierte
dempsey sich besser aus ihrer barometer
ab jetzt braucht einen politischen star
über den grand canyon kwf ließ sie aber
im laden genau diejenigen wieder gefragt
habe ich noch kein goal
die suche sei unklar so ist also egal ob
groß sowie und hof sowie gold zum gang
zum konkursrichter so wurde der bis
heute drogenopfer k
um die vergessene der blick wochen
ausgesagt was welt informiert
warum hätte man anders momente oder zwar
weniger darum geduldig alle aber
vielleicht sollte normal blick sie
verdienen bevor ihr die dianetik von
möbel gang der blick vom augenblick kann
man versucht
stolte zum beispiel ganz ruhig
schnuppertour nach ein hort des wiener
linien umsätze und chance den xi den
jemen mit gastro groß ist
es ist jetzt alexandra chinas ist
sterbebegleiterin und lola sie ist eine
therapie hündin und ebenfalls
sterbebegleiterin und herr stefan
eichmüller ist professor für
palliativmedizin an der universität bern
und leitet auch am inselspital in bern
die abteilung für palliativmedizin schön
sind sie da ja frau schiller von ihnen
würde ich gerne zuerst einmal besser
verstehen was eigentlich eine
sterbebegleiterin macht was genau tun
sie was angehörige an einem bett eines
sterbenden nicht tun können
im kern sind wir einfach menschen die in
einer ganz besonderen zeit neu auf
menschen zugehen wir sind nichts anderes
als jeder von uns hier was wir geben
kann ist zeit und zuwendung und das zu
jeder zeit und bedingungslos ohne
vorgeschichte auch es ist ja sehr
unterschiedlich je nachdem kann die
begegnung sehr kurz sein sie kann sich
aber auch über wochen monate entwickeln
was dann natürlich auch sehr schön ist
aber wir sind insofern nichts besonderes
sterbebegleitung ist darf mich auch
nicht zwingend passendes wort wir sind
ja wir begleiten ja nicht das sterben
sondern wir begleiten menschen die in
einer letzten phase ihres lebens sich
befinden
in diesem sinne aber interessant fand
ich jetzt gar den punkt dass es
vielleicht auch darum geht eine
geschichte gar nicht zu kennen
vorbehaltlos zu sein das heißt der
sterbende kann sich vielleicht auch an
vertrauen mit dingen die er den
verwandten nicht sagen möchte
ja das kann sein es ist einfach eine
gewisse unbelastet haid heer von von
dieser perspektive die beziehungen zu
den menschen entwickelt sich auch ganz
unterschiedlich man muss sich das
wirklich so vorstellen dass eben die
menschen so unterschiedlich sind wie im
leben auch und da geben sich dann auch
ganz verschiedenste arten von
begegnungen themen oder auch keine
themen je nachdem
sitzt man auch einfach da und gibt seine
zeit
und was macht lola luna macht genau das
genau
und noch viel besser als wir menschen
weil sie ein hund ist geht sie noch mit
viel mehr unbeschwerte leichtigkeit auf
die menschen zu und stellt keine fragen
will auch nichts wissen sondern freut
sich an der begegnung und sie haben mir
auch erzählt dass es manchmal die
situation gibt das lola instinktiv sich
zu sterben personen legt die sterbende
person vielleicht auch abdeckt was dann
die verwandten der sterbenden person
vielleicht gar nicht so schätzen die
sterbende person unter umständen aber
schon
ja es gibt da einen prozess es gibt ein
prozess wo der mensch der sich eben in
dieser letzten phase befindet noch sehr
gut auch selber lenken kann was er was
sie oder er kann oder will
und dann gibt es eine phase wo der
mensch schon sich auf seiner reise
befindet und wo dann die angehörigen
wichtiger werden und das ist auch für
uns ganz wichtig zu erkennen weil wir
dann eben sehr gut auch achten müssen
was für die angehörigen richtig und
wichtig ist in dieser zeit genau wie
müller gibt es auch auf ihrer
palliativstation tiere ja mit großen
bedenken der spitalhygiene es ist
natürlich an einem universitätsspital
braucht es auch bauliche voraussetzungen
und wir haben das glück dass wir in
einem separaten gebäude sind auch die
begegnung stattfinden kann im sommer
noch viel besser als im winter nämlich
außerhalb auf einem sitzplatz und das
passt eigentlich auch zur begegnung sehr
gut dazu dass man halt nicht als patient
in seinem krankenzimmer ist sondern dass
man draußen auch in der natur ist und es
wird auch sehr geschätzt vor allem von
menschen die halt verbal nicht alles von
sich geben können oder wollen wo man
auch mal den mund halten kann und man
hat trotzdem zuwendungen
trotzdem kann man so ein warmes feldern
kraulen zum beispiel es gibt eine studie
von der universität zürich von michaela
töne seiner soziologin die hat
untersucht wie tiere in der letzten
lebensphase auf das wohlbefinden von
menschen wirken und sie sagt tiere sind
so etwas wie eine palliativ ressource
würden sie das bestätigen
ja es gibt sogar
kein anderes buch das heißt oskar deecke
und das hat es immerhin auf die
titelseite des berühmtesten
medizinischen chance gebracht das new
england journal of medicine und diese
katze hat in einem pflege- und
altersheimen in rochester gewohnt und
war immer die ankündigung des todes dh
die ist immer ungefähr 24 stunden vor
dem eintreten des todes auf das bett
ihrer bewohnerinnen gesprungen und hat
diese intuition die wir heute
wissenschaftlich nachweisen können wie
wichtig das ist dass wir die haben und
spüren hat die tatze uns weit voraus
wahrscheinlich und das sind viel zu pro
kopf und ich glaube lola hat er auch
sowas ist es so merkt lola wenn jemand
wirklich gestorben ist ein tier hat
natürlich ein anderes denkschema als der
mensch also ich ohne lola dass ich jetzt
für sich sprechen möchte aber ich
versuche ich kann mir ich denke nicht
dass sie eben mit dem gleichen mit der
gleichen vorstellung da hingeht und
denkt dieser mensch stirbt aber ich
denke mir sie empfindet sehr klar eine
besondere empfindsamkeit und
empfänglichkeit des menschen für für die
begegnung und das liegt die halt sehr
das ist in ihrer natur eben kontakt und
und bindung aufzubauen
nun ist es ja so dass dieses sterben das
zu ende gehen eines lebens das läuft
nach einem biologischen programm ab
könnte man fast schon sagen da gibt es
gewisse dinge die sind doch immer
ungefähr gleich und wie das genau
vonstatten geht schauen wir uns an in
einem beitrag in dem das sterben eines
menschen nachgestellt wird
schon seit tagen hat der kranke viel
geschlafen und kaum noch gesprochen
erste zeichen für einen biologisch
vorgegebenes programm sterben der körper
fett den stoffwechsel zurück ein sterben
der organismus baut nichts mehr auf
deshalb verweigern die patienten essen
und trinken ihr gehirn schüttet stress
botenstoffe aus hunger und durst hören
auf auch das gehört zum sterbeprozess
sonden die nährlösung zu führen werden
meistens entfernt die mediziner bestehen
nicht auf künstlicher nahrungs oder
flüssigkeitszufuhr
das macht angehörigen oft angst und
ärzte müssen es erklären denn gerade die
austrocknung ist für den sterbenden gut
nur dann schüttet das gehirn weitere
stoffe aus die beruhigen und schmerzen
lindern so genannte endogene opiate
als nächstes werden hände und füße kalt
das blut zieht sich zurück
der kreislauf reduziert sich auf die
wichtigsten organe im körperinneren
lunge herz und gehirn
der patient wird unruhig er macht
fahrigen bewegungen
[Musik]
an den füßen sieht der pfleger dass die
haut fleckig wird ergebnis der
verminderten durchblutung auch die
zehennägel färben sich blau
außerdem hören magen und darm
aufzuarbeiten
die nieren werden nicht mehr durchblutet
und produzieren könne nur ihn mehr
giftstoffe sammeln sich im blut an es
wird nicht mehr gereinigt die folge die
gifte lehman das gehirn
der patient wird bewusstlos noch atmet
er regelmäßig aber mit jedem atemzug
kommt ein brodelndes rasseln
es liegt daran dass das sterben der
nicht mehr husten und schnupfen kann
rachen und bronchien füllen sich mit
schleim der das rasseln verursacht
obwohl der patient bewusstlos ist da
sind sich die ärzte sicher spürt der
sterbende dass er umsorgt wird
berührungen und vertraute musikschaffen
geborgenheit
zuletzt wird der atem unregelmäßig das
sterben der schnappt nach luft das ist
das zeichen dafür dass das herz nicht
mehr richtig schlägt
und schließlich stillsteht jetzt bricht
die sauerstoffversorgung des körpers
zusammen und das gehirn setzt aus ein
friedlicher tot doch jeder stirbt anders
ein riesiger tross doch jeder stift
anders beides wirft fragen auf wie ich
einerseits war das ein friedlicher tod
und wie genau heißt anders sterben das
ist gemeint damit ich glaube wir können
mit unserer wissenschaftlichkeit und
vorher hieß es jeder der jetzt weiter
redet ist ein quatschkopf da hören wir
in diesem punkt auf wir können einiges
wissen was die körper vorgänge sind so
wie geschildert in diesem beitrag
wir können auch beobachten als
außenstehende das sind übrigens die
pflegenden freiwillige und mediziner
aber auch sehr viele angehörige mit
beteiligt aber wir interpretieren dann
sehr viel weil sie leitet der mensch
jetzt oder nicht
und dann kommt auch die dritte ebene und
das ist das erleben der person und da
haben wir um ganz ehrlich zu sein keine
ahnung weil diese menschen nicht davon
berichten können genau und wir hatten
vorher in frau wenig gehört vielleicht
ist das manchmal so ein fingerzeig wie
könnte es sein wenn wir über nahtod
erlebnisse nachdenken und das hat auch
etwas sehr schönes und beruhigendes und
es gibt auch sehr viel literatur darüber
und auf der anderen seite stehen wir an
dem punkt dass wir sagen das ist das
große geheimnis unseres lebens genauso
wenig vielleicht wie wir wissen was mit
dem kind vor dem durchtritt innen
drinnen bauch passiert ich glaube auch
nicht dass man da sehr viel weiß was da
passiert haben sie selber angst moment
tut es gibt ein wunderbares buch das
gegen die angst ist und es ist von
tiziano terzani das ende ist mein anfang
das ist eine berichterstattung eines
sohnes zusammen mit seinem vater der
stirbt und er sagt das einzige was mir
vielleicht noch passieren kann weil er
ein weitgereister journalist war der
vater auf der ganzen welt das einzige
was mir vielleicht noch spannendes
passieren kann ist der tod
ich hoffe dass das bei mir so wird und
wahrscheinlich werden sich viele
menschen gar nicht hinterher darüber
unterhalten wie es war ein bisschen
hofft man ja dann immer dass zwei
palliativmediziner oder eine
sterbebegleiterin 1
sagen man muss keine angst haben haben
sie denn angst frau schiller wesentlich
weniger als vor der zeit wo ich mich mit
dem thema habe begonnen eben inter sie
intensiver auch zu beschäftigen und ich
kann das wirklich auch jeden anraten
vielleicht nicht gleich scharf 20 ist da
hat man noch keine energie dazu da sind
andere themen vordergründig aber ich
denke mir ab der mitte des lebens tut
man gut daran hin zu sehen ist es macht
ja eben auch angst und bekanntlich und
sagt ja auch da wo die angst ist geht es
lang
und das sterben kann schon sehr viel
vorher beginnen wir alle bekommen falten
sind weniger fit das sind alles elemente
davon dass eben das uns zeigt dass das
leben nicht endlich ist das hatte herbig
ja vorhin auch schon so gesagt dass
eigentlich der tod ist schon mitten im
leben vorhanden mit dem abbau dem
körperlichen pedro lenz hat auch
aufgeworfen dass man immer so denkt man
sagt das ja auch sehr oft dass man
einfacher stirbt wenn man sich in diesem
loslassen stimmt das deckt sich das mit
der erfahrung
also ich kann nur berichten von menschen
die das loslassen nicht so gut konnten
das geht auch bis zu dem punkt dass es
menschen gibt die sagen ich möchte jetzt
sterben und dieses ganz dezidierte jetzt
ist genug
das ist auch nicht einfach zu starten
und dann gibt es noch eine zweite gruppe
von menschen und es sind aus meiner
wahrnehmung die menschen die gegen ihren
willen sehr alleine sind und einsamkeit
und das lebensende wenn die einsamkeit
nicht gut erlebt wird ist offensichtlich
auch sehr schwierig so ist
wahrscheinlich dieses miteinander
richtung lebensende ist ein sehr
wichtiges medikament wie ist es mit den
schmerzen kann man heute wirklich sagen
das muss niemand mehr mit schmerzen
sterben kann man alles sage jetzt mal
weg therapieren
ja da könnten wir eine einzelne stadt
stunde darüber machen weil schmerz ist
natürlich ein riesiges phänomen
und wenn wir nur medikalisierung in der
sterbephase ansagen dieser mensch hat
jetzt einen schmerz chor von 0 bis 10
irgendwo bei 7 wahrscheinlich wenn die
person auskunft geben kann und dann
geben wir so und so viele medikamente
das ist wahrscheinlich falsch ich denke
unter jedem schmerz wie in einem eisberg
kann sich ganz viel verbergen
da können sich sehr viel sorgen da
können sich sehr viel ungeordnete
geschäfte die noch zukunft zu machen
sind zu bergen
da kann unglaublicher stress darin seien
todesangst reagiert haben und das alles
zeigt sich als schmerz oder wir
übersetzen dass das heißt das können wir
beileibe nicht mit medikamenten
behandeln und wir können auch nicht
jeden menschen garantieren sie können
ohne schmerzen sterben
was man aber auch weiß ist dass das
jeder angehörige hofft und wünscht bitte
wenigstens ohne schmerzen sterben
menschen schlimm ist und trotzdem geben
sterbende solange sie es können
hoffentlich nur in einem relativ
geringen prozentsatz schmerz als das
haupt phänomen an
es gibt eine studie der industriellen
die gesucht versucht hat unter vielen
tausenden menschen in dieser phase das
zu erfassen das sind nur vier bis sieben
prozent die gesagt haben das ist mein
hauptthema
was sind denn die anderen themen das
hauptsächliche war diese unendliche
schwäche dass man auch nicht mehr in der
lage ist kontakt aufzunehmen
und da kommt dann das thema lassen
loslassen können und sei nicht mehr
kämpfen müssen aber auch von den
angehörigen dass sie sagen ist okay
vielleicht vielleicht noch eine letzte
frage zu diesen schmerzen es ist
trotzdem so dass auch wiederum sage ich
jetzt mal was man sich erzählt was man
hört sehr viele menschen morphine
erhalten zum ende des lebens gibt es
überhaupt noch das was man einen
natürlichen tod nennt wir haben ja
vorher gehört in der präsentation
und wir sind zum körper abläuft dass wir
selber endorphine ausschütten
in dieser phase weil es eine
stresssituation ist unsere
und da wird alles mobilisiert und das
können wir unterstützen durch externe
gaben von morphium von opioiden und
eigentlich diesen zusatzeffekt nutzen
gegen das vielleicht auch angespannt
sein und morphine patient zum beispiel
auch gut gegen angst und trotzdem hat es
in dem volksmund natürlich das totale
bild jetzt kommt für monat kommt der tod
und das wegen wird sich das auch sehr
oft ganz andere lebensweisen aus und
sagt du gottes willen kein morphium habe
ich denke in dem moment ist es wie ein
unterstützer der natürlichen abläufe im
körper und wir müssen aber da keine
monströsen dosen geben sondern versuchen
dranzubleiben auch mit verschiedenen
beobachtungen was es vielleicht auch
weniger braucht ich danke ihnen ganz
herzlich wir sehen uns nachher noch
einmal danke für das gespräch
ja manche menschen manche menschen
sterben da wo vermutlich niemand von uns
sterben möchte im spital auf der
intensivstation angehängt an schläuche
und maschinen im fall von cory 19
vielleicht sogar einsam ohne angehörige
bei mir sitzt jetzt peter steiger ist
intensivmediziner und stellvertretender
instituts direkt oder intensiv medizin
am unispital zürich herrscht ein piepsen
de maschinen schläuche wie sieht dieser
tod aus mit dem sie im alltag leider
auch manchmal konfrontiert sind
solange die maschinen tiefsten und
regelmäßig piepsen ist das vielleicht
ein ganz gutes zeichen dann lädt prozent
noch und auf der intensivstation wird
nicht nur gestorben ist wird vielleicht
noch wichtig seien 90 prozent überleben
aber zehn prozent etwa versterben das
ist wirklich so und wie das aussieht ist
noch schwierig zu sagen es gibt ganz
verschiedene arten zu sterben
zum beispiel es gibt zum beispiel die
art sich relativ selten zum glück wo
unser patient wirklich unter voller
therapie vielleicht sogar unter
reanimation unter den händen weg stirbt
das ist nicht sehr schön ganz viele
leute am bett 567 vielleicht sehen leute
wir versuchen den patienten ins leben
zurückzuholen und reanimieren und
spritzen medikamente und so weiter der
häufige retro auf der intensivstation
ist aber heutzutage eine therapie
rückzug bis hinter unterdessen relativ
weit in der intensivmedizin so dass wir
patienten sehr lange am leben erhalten
können
und häufig ist es so dass der lauf dann
schlussendlich einfach auf zeigt dieser
patient wird diese krankheit hat diesen
unfall nicht überleben oder er wird
nicht so überleben wie er sich vorstellt
dass er auch noch weiterleben könnte und
im gespräch mit den angehörigen
versuchen wir das herauszufinden was ist
das ziel des patienten ist das noch mit
seinem mutmaßlichen ort noch besser
dokumentierten willen frei
in einer patientenverfügung zum beispiel
genau richtig und wenn das nicht mehr
der fall ist spricht man darüber aber
ein therapie abbruch machen sollen was
ist was sie dann was ist für sie
schwieriger von diesen zwei arten zu
sterben sozusagen unter den eigenen
händen oder dann mit einer bewussten
entscheidung die maschine abzuschauen
das schwieriger ist wenn der patient
einem unter den händen weg stirbt wenn
man wirklich noch alles versucht und man
weise diese patient der sollte nicht
sterben in anführungszeichen
das ist viel schwieriger für alle und da
gibt es dann auch ein gespräch mit allen
beteiligten wie es die ganze ist auch
hier abgelaufen ist die reanimation
abgelaufen ist alles so gelaufen ich
sollte haben wir fehler gemacht haben
wir keine fehler gemacht und gehen sie
damit vorwürfen um einerseits vielleicht
von angehörigen aber auch vorwürfe die
sie an sich selbst richten gibt es dass
es schwieriger ist wenn man etwas
übersehen hat schon einen fehler gemacht
hat teilweise gibt es situationen weiß
man genau ok weiß noch nicht genau was
der patient hat wenn ich jetzt in diese
richtung gehe und der patient hat genau
darauf hier bin ich falsch
das ist natürlich sehr schlimm aber das
kommt zum glück sehr selten vor und hier
ist es eben wichtig dass das ganze team
mitarbeiters alle mit denken dass alle
ihre meinung dazu sagen können und von
von dem er ist das ein thema brot gibt
es so etwas wie ein würdevolles sterben
auf einer intensivstation und wenn ja
was heißt das hier muss ich sie fragen
was verstehen sie unter würdevollen
sterben
ich sage ja das gibt es und zwar genau
in diesen fällen wo man eine therapie
abbruch macht dass man sagt okay gut
schalten wir die medikamente wir nehmen
unsere unterstützung auf medizinischer
seite nehmen wir von patienten weg und
schauen aber wie wir das vor gehört
haben dass der patient nicht im stress
ist
wir geben ihm medikamente wir wissen er
stirbt sowieso kann nicht überleben so
und schauen dass er nicht in den strich
kurt gruppe gehören dazu beruhigende
medikamente gehören dazu aber die hat
der patient auch vorher schon gehabt
aber trotzdem gibt es ja diese phase
kurz vor dem tod wo es nach regelungen
gibt reaktionen des körpers vielleicht
schnappt jemand noch nach luft als
angehöriger stelle ich mir das ziemlich
angsteinflößend
ja ist es ganz wichtig mit den
angehörigen vorzusprechen und zu sagen
was für reaktionen hervorgerufen werden
können wenn man zum beispiel eben die
beatmung abschaltet und auch zu sagen
dass es solche reaktionen gibt an
lazarus phänomen sagt man dem
tatsächlich dass wenn das hier nicht
mehr funktioniert und zeigen nicht die
reaktionen die einen körper automatisch
hätte eine berührung macht dass man
zurückzieht dass es nicht mehr
funktioniert und so einfach noch reflexe
rheine wird das rückenmark funktionieren
dass bewegung und teilweise auch spontan
der berührung dazu führen können dass
der patient sich bewegt und das kann
also ziemlich groteske formen annehmen
und also das schlimmste was ich je
gesehen habe war wir christus der
patient schlussendlich noch mal beide
arme nach vorne gemessen hat und das
sieht dann aus wie eine umarmung oder
sowas
und wenn man das nicht weiß also unter
vieren könnt dann schon bei dem toten
geht es aber auch im sterbeprozess kann
das passieren
und wenn man dann nicht davor gefeit ist
dieses relativ schwierig ich bringe dann
jeweils auch das beispiel das nicht sehr
schön ist natürlich habe mindestens die
älteren patienten können die kennen das
noch wenn man ein huhn schlacht jetzt
tönt jetzt nicht schön auf dem bauernhof
den kopf abschlägt oder ist das tun ja
nicht einfach schlafen tod sollen genau
das bewegt und auf den flügel und fliegt
vielleicht noch und das kann auch beim
menschen passiert ich meine sie
betreuten betreuen auch sowie 19
patienten
und da ist es also dass da vielerorts
angehörig keinen zutritt haben
wir haben ein paar bilder vorbereitet
wie das aussieht auf der intensivstation
da sieht man einen kollegen von ihnen am
unispital zürich
ich stelle mir vor hat wenn man dann so
einsam ist
das ist für alle beteiligten ein
schrecklicher tod angehängt an diese
beatmungsmaschine jetzt es ist nicht so
dass wir also angehörige nicht dabei
sein dürfen wenn bei einer solchen
patient die therapie eingestellt wird
unterdessen das manko wie patienten auch
besuchen und schon in der ersten welle
haben wir gesagt beim sterben so werden
dass absehbar ist darf besucht dabei
sein
was wir aber nicht gestattet habe dann
nicht wollten ist dass man sich über den
patienten wirft ganz nahe ist gesicht
bei gesicht aber man durfte dabei sein
und durch seinen patienten berühren
natürlich in schutzkleidung mit maske
das ist speziell aber der patient ist
nicht als eine freundin und diese
abschiede über videotelefonie oder sowas
wird das überhaupt gewünscht das sind
diese menschen einfach so unter atemnot
dass das überhaupt nicht wollen die
patienten bei denen wir die therapie
auch die veranstalter auf der
intensivstation sind meistens nicht bei
bewusstsein sondern die werden bei auf
die center unter beruhigungsmittel die
sind unter opiaten und kriegen das gar
nicht richtig mit wenn man sich wie sie
täglich mit dem tod auseinandersetzen
muss dagegen kämpft
was hat das für einen einfluss auf ihr
leben macht das mit ihnen also was ich
gelernt habe ist dass der tod kommt wann
er kommt dass man das leben teilweise
vorsichtige führen muss ich überhole
nicht mehr so wie früher in jungen
jahren wenn ein lastwagen wurde ist oder
ein traktors und überlege mir lohnt es
sich jetzt diese zwei minuten zeitgewinn
oder ist ihr recht daraus
ich versuche mich aber nicht auf den tod
zu fokussieren sondern aufs leben und
das ist ja auch mein ziel aber als arzt
eigentlich hat man nicht nur die aufgabe
patienten am leben zu erhalten sondern
hat auch die aufgabe patienten in einen
guten tod zu begleiten wenn wir sehen
dass das andere nicht mehr im sinn von
patienten ist so der aussichtslos ist
ganz kurz nach was heißt das in einem
guten tod begleiten in einen tod ohne
stress auf der intensivstation
hersteller vielen herzlichen dank für
diesen kurzen einblick danke
kann ich würde gerne noch einmal dieses
motiv aufnehmen des kreislauf des lebens
sie haben gaben damit eigentlich unsere
sendung angefangen dass sie gesagt haben
alles ist ein kreislauf und der biologe
bernd heinrich hat ein wunderbares buch
dazu geschrieben und er beschreibt das
so dass er sagt zu ihm hatte das was
tröstliches zu wissen dass der körper
wenn wir sterben wenn wir ihn verlesen
lassen ja auch wieder nahrung ist für
ganz viele lebewesen für bakterien für
pilze vier raben für ameisen für käfer
für magen und so weiter hat das für sie
auch etwas tröstliches abhängiger ja so
etwas normales und friedlich ist weil
das von den herzen her gehört haben das
ist auch etwas stressfreies geht und wir
haben sie gerade da sagst das finde ich
auch also es ist unheimlich stressfrei
zu sehen mich dass wir uns schon kurz
erwähnt habe dass wir wirklich auf das
material angewiesen sind ohne eisen
können nicht atmen auf der erde reisen
entstanden
folglich gehören wir alle zusammen und
die ganzen lebewesen die gehören hat
auch alle zu uns die sind ja in der easy
in riesigen nahrungsnetze ndr- in den
raum und zeit zu denen wir einfach auch
gehören also ich ja friedlich ist
vielleicht der beste begriff tröstlich
also brauche ich gar kein ich will auch
nur frieden haben und in der biologie
und in der welt des lebens herrschte
frieden weil es halt alles so
miteinander zusammenhängt ist gerade
miteinander zusammenhängen ich komme
gleich zu ihnen mit dem kreislauf -
zuerst auch wissen warum sie keinen
trost brauchen die meisten sagen doch
der tod das ist schon so ein einbruch in
die existenzen die menschliche wir
suchen nach trost sie nicht keine ahnung
vielleicht gibt es manche menschen die
halten sich für schlaue oder größer als
andere und denken deswegen das wäre
schade wenn sie sterben aber es ist ja
man soll ja man soll ein schönes leben
haben und in der zeit das machen was was
halt schön für die betreffende person
ist wie sie das auch gesagt haben
und das ist ja schon das tolle also das
wie ein computerspiel was man geschenkt
bekommen hat ohne da zwei franken
reingeschmissen zu haben also immer
kriegt ja grad sollte man sich darüber
freuen und nicht dann die ganze zeit an
den tod denken und sich darüber trösten
lassen müssen dass das jetzt irgendwann
vorbei ist das spiel kann sie mit trost
etwas anfangen und nur sehr bedingt auch
also dieser kreislauf geschichte tröstet
mich jetzt persönlich auch nicht sehr
auch in der begleitung hinterbliebener
ist
doch ein sehr großes wort also es ist
eher ein wahrgenommen werden einen
würdigen des erlebens der trauernden
aber trost ist eine große kategorie
sprechen wir noch einmal über diesen
kreislauf der kreis auf gedanke den kann
man eben biologisch deutschen aber da
wird natürlich auch oft religiös
bedeutet zb die idee der das rad der
wiedergeburten im buddhismus gibt viele
menschen die glauben daran wiedergeboren
zu werden
aber auch die christliche idee dass der
lebenskreis sich schließt wie man so
spricht dann das ewige leben kommt das
ist dann kein kreislauf aber zumindest
etwas was weitergeht
was ist ihre erfahrung hilft religion
beim sterben also als notfall psychologe
oder der tätigkeit auch als bestatter 50
50 also es kann sein dass religiöse
menschen dann sehr ins haar ankommen was
ist jetzt mit diesen barmherzigen gott
und warum hat mein kind sterben müssen
umgekehrt gibt es auch das dass menschen
dann sehr wohl trost finden oder rang
hatte mal gesagt die schlaueste
erfindung des menschen war die erfindung
der seele also um uns sozusagen über
diesen tod zu erheben und das treffen
auch nicht durch alle religionen oder
esoterischen strömungen auch auf dieses
bei ihnen herr ich mich aber ich denke
dass das thema spiritualität spielt bei
uns schon eine große rolle und das ist
vielleicht das bessere wort sich
geborgen aufgehoben fühlen in etwas und
wir erleben sehr viele menschen die
dieses etwas suchen das kann ein
haustier sein
das kann aber auch eine natur begegnung
sein das können aber auch gedanken
reißen sein oder das kann eine klare
religiöse verortung sein wo ich sage da
fühle ich mich sicher und auch geführt
vom wie seitz ins jenseits
und ich glaube das ist ich hab vorher
gesagt das bleibt ja ein geheimnis was
passiert dann haben wir endlich auch die
möglichkeit uns diese welt in die wir
gehen oder in das seien auch selber so
vorzustellen dass wir möglichst wenig
angst dabei habe
und manchmal machen dass die kinder ganz
hervorragend wenn der kinder bieten zum
beispiel für ihre sterben dann was
manchmal auch schwierig ist eltern oder
auf die großeltern wie ein bild zu malen
da ist extrem viel tröstliches drin da
gibt es diesen kreislauf und dann werden
sie engel und dann kommen sie vielleicht
als engel wieder suchen sie sich einen
bauch bei einem netten ehepaaren kommen
wieder zurück solche dinge und ich
glaube wir können da von den kindern was
lernen weil oft wird das dann als
tröstlich erleben das ist dann unsere
interpretation und ich glaube wir dürfen
uns solche steigbügel bauen damit wir
nicht erstarren in der sorge und angst
es ist das ja auch so ein bisschen
niedlich dargestellt man versteht das
gut bei den kindern die malen dann engel
und regenbogen und so weiter aber ich
glaube trotzdem dass viele menschen ja
so eine sehnsucht tagen irgendwie diesem
tod oder diesem sterben einen sinn
einzuhauchen
es gibt vom philosophen epikur die idee
dass der tod für uns nicht schlecht sein
könnte weil wenn ihr tod sind sind wir
auch nicht mehr da das heißt wir erleben
diesen tod nicht und wenn wir noch etwas
erleben sind wir noch nicht tot
insofern kann der tod nicht schlecht
sein für uns und ich habe glaube ich
noch selten jemanden gefunden der gesagt
hat das findet er jetzt wirklich
überzeugend und tröstlich wie geht es
ihnen herr benecke das von epikur ja ja
das ist ein bisschen vergaß ich bin der
erde in den laden also das ist mag
vielleicht philosophisch logisch sein
das kann ich jetzt nicht nachvollziehen
also nicht beurteilen meine ich mit
meiner wissenschaft aber wie ich schon
sagte also ich finde es super dass alles
material erhalten bleibt und wieder was
neues bildet früher oder später das kann
ja auch steine und wasser und erstmal
für ablagerungen bilden und so aber dass
das ist die das ist die geborgenheit das
ist der trost dass es mein steigbügel
und es ist die wahrheit noch dazu dass
auch sehr praktisch
deswegen da da fühle ich mich gut
aufgehoben
ich würde gerne mit ihnen sprechen in
einigen jahrzehnten wenn sie alles gibt
wirklich näher rückt das ich frage mich
mache ist das nicht das privileg der
jungen sitzen die irgendwie denken mir
kann das alles nichts anhaben ich habe
davor keine angst
ist es nicht auch irgendwie menschlich
oder etwas was uns dann irgendwann doch
gefällt diese angst glauben sie nicht
dass wie es bei jedem anders also jeder
mensch er hat ja einen ganz anderen
charakter und ein ganz anderer
zusammengehören zusammensetzung und
andere erlebnisse im leben und andere
religiöse oder spirituelle überzeugungen
und so also dass das ich glaube ich dass
das altersabhängig ist also zum beispiel
sie haben das ja vorhin auch schön
geschildert wenn jemand zum beispiel
diese nahtod erfahrungen gemacht oder
von mir aus auch starke seelische
erfahrungen oder irgendetwas lebens
einschneiden ist das kann ja auch was
ganz anderes leben möglich sein denn
dann wie sie das ja super geschildert
haben dann lebt man ja auch schon ein
bisschen in der anderen welt drücken
und da das für jeden anders ist glaube
ich nicht dass das altersabhängig sein
muss also ich finde diesen epikur
ziemlich cool
und zwar deshalb weil wir eigentlich
jeden tag uns vorstellen könnten
vielleicht ist es der letzte und ihn wie
viele sitzungen würden sie morgen gehen
wenn sie wüssten das ist mein letzter
tag oder mit wem würde ich morgen in
beziehung treten wollen würde ich lieber
meine familie umarmen wollen würde ich
lieber theater riechen oder sowas und
ich glaube wenn man hier mit dem zug
nach zürich herr einfährt dann stellt
man sich schon die frage wäre das nicht
jeden tag eine gute überlegung
man muss aber auch sagen wer jetzt nicht
jeden tag ein luxus sich diese
überlegungen machen zu dürfen wie viele
menschen können nicht so leben dass sie
dem platz geben können was sie tun
werden am letzten tag prozent bedienen
einverstanden und das hat auch mit 19
oder diese pandemie uns gezeigt wie
privilegiert wir hinter schweiz leben
und dass wir beziehungen haben unsere
grundbedürfnisse gesichert sind und und
das ist sicher toll aber ich denke wenn
man auch in anderen ländern der welt
schon gearbeitet hat ist diese basale
zufriedenheit mit dem leben und das
leben feiern jeden tag ist zum teil
deutlich verbreiteter als bei uns und
nicht warten auf die pensionierung wo
angefangen wird mit leben und als auch
eine frage ist des sozialen status nicht
nur der anderen länder
oben an diese möglichkeiten habt ja aber
ich glaube auch die etappierung des
lebens ab wann darf jetzt richtig frei
losgelassen werden
mit leben das erleben wir oft und wir
erleben auch eine überraschende häufung
von schweren erkrankungen zu beginn des
rentenalters und ich glaube das muss man
schon auch sich überlegen ist das
gescheit dann nicht die bucket list
früher schon mal anzufangen zu leben
also das kann ich auch wirklich
bestätigen weil ich viele sehr armen
ländern arbeite wirklich sehr sehr armen
ländern und ich sehe da natürlich
abgesehen von den gründen die wir jetzt
in den reichen industrieländern kennen
sehe ich auch überhaupt keinen
zusammenhang also gerade zum beispiel
naturverbundenheit nahtod erlebnisse so
weiter das gibt es in allen kulturen die
ich in meinem leben gesehen habe überall
gleich das ist nicht vom
sozioökonomischen verhältnisse
hauptsächlich abhängig zumindest nicht
meiner beobachtung
das war jetzt nicht der punkt ich meinte
nur dieses privileg jeden tag so leben
zu können das wäre es der letzte was ja
schon ideal ist für viele aber nach dem
spiel und männer studieren wir machen
das in den armen ländern die leben jeden
tag sowieso wollen halten wir mit sehr
geringen möglichkeiten und natürlich
hätten die sich ja auch das eine oder
andere gerne mehr aber wahrscheinlich
wird im studio hat auch der eine oder
andere gerne mehr also das ist das ist
nichts was jetzt die industrieländer für
einen armen ländern unbedingt so stark
unterscheidet oder vom sozialen status
lassen sie mich so ein bisschen zur zur
letzten frau gekommen nämlich zur frage
was wird es dann heißen so eine memento
mori einstellung zu haben also so eine
einstellung immer im angesicht des todes
zu leben oder im angesichts des wissens
dass wir sterblich sind wäre das eine
haltung die dann wozu führt ihrer
meinung nach eher klein
naja was immer sie können jeden tag weiß
ich nicht aber der philosoph epikur was
sie vorher geschildert haben hier sehen
wir auch dass wir mit rationalen
philosophischen klimmzügen hier nicht
sehr weit kommen
ob durchschnittsrate mal geschrieben 40
grad fieber schwere atemnot und die
auskunft dass man ihn zweimal
tot sein wird und dann kann man schauen
was uns vor philosophiert wir sollen
erkennen dass wir glaube ich viele dinge
aufrichten kulturelle weltbilder götter
seelen was auch immer um damit irgendwie
fertig werden zu können aber wir sollen
erkennen dass wir es deswegen tun und
letztlich würden wir erkennen dass wir
nichts anderes haben wahrscheinlich
außer uns und da könnte man noch viel
mehr energie darauf hin richten dann
würden wir auch vielleicht dazu kommen
dass es selbstverständlich ist dass wir
sehen müssen dass es allen möglichst gut
geht auf der welt so lange es irgendwie
geht und dass wir uns so weit sozusagen
vor unmäßigkeit und krankheit und
schmerzen gegenseitig schützen können
verstehe ich sie richtig dass dieses uns
sozial zu verstehen ist aber nicht nur
wir haben uns als gemeinschaft der
menschen
wir haben ja die beziehung aus
eigentlich nur ein moment von mori heißt
für sie eigentlich beziehungen haben
nicht was uns im sinn von sozialen sinne
ja ich glaube da kann man morgen gleich
anfangen wir hatten die möglichkeit mit
dem stadtpräsidenten in bern eine
sogenannte compassion city charta zu
lancieren wo es darum geht eine
sterbekultur in eine stadt irgendwie
zumindest meinen ersten stein oder einen
ersten tropfen ins wasser zugießen zu
sagen was entwickelt sich daraus das
geht von der täglichen übung los was er
vorher aufgehört hatten wie gehe ich mit
den nachbarn um wo jemand gestorben ist
wechsele ich das trottoir auf die andere
seite ag 'ich würde ich auf die andere
person zu das ist das was er meinte aber
das geht noch weiter nämlich was lernen
wir in der schule wie gehen wir mit dem
thema endlichkeit umlernen wir
vielleicht auch die mit variablen und
abhängigen personen solidarische
umzugehen und das kann ja änderung
beglückend sein und ich glaube das ist
keine sozialromantik sondern das können
wir jetzt im hier und jetzt und morgen
können wir das umsetzen und können
dadurch die beziehung der beziehung
einen sehr hohen wert geben und
gleichzeitig aber auch dem thema
lebensende in der gesellschaft einen
hohen wert und es vielleicht auch für
mich alle so brennt werden über
jahrzehnte haben wir es geschafft die
angst vor dem leben
zu bearbeiten und zu sagen die geburt
ist nicht mehr der horror sondern wir
haben sehr viele gute dinge macht kann
information bildung dann kurse dann
beste medizinische versorgung und
finanzierung und was uns eigentlich
jetzt ansteht und sie hat das vorher von
jeanne borasio angetönt ist dasselbe mit
dem lebensende zu machen wie gut sind
wir denn informiert über das was am
lebensende passiert so wie heute was wir
besprechen
wie gut haben wir eine information was
es für netzwerke gibt wenn wir selber
95% des tages unsere angehörigen sorgen
müssen nur fünf prozent die vacha so nah
doch quasi letzte hilfe kurse in einem
wiener große sondern auch ein
politisches engagement zu sagen das hat
einen riesen hohen wert wenn wir das
ernst nehmen sagen wir wollen kollektiv
weniger angst haben am lebensende
ich bin sehr über zurück und das haben
andere gesellschaften auch gezeigt wie
zum beispiel australien dass das sehr
viel bewegt barkeit drin ist das kann
man über solche compassion es probieren
und das kann man aber auch in der schule
starten
und jetzt von der gesellschaft wieder
zurück zu dem die waadt leben würde ich
ganz gerne noch von frau schiller und
frau minne hören was ist denn für sie
heißt den tod ins leben zu intelligent
omori frau schiller was haben sie ist
das wichtigste was sie gelernt haben mit
aus der intensiven beschäftigung mit dem
tod für ihr leben ja ich glaube ich habe
mittlerweile einen deutlich
pragmatischeren zugang zu dem was
sterben heißt und auch was das leben
heißt also wir müssen uns sicher zu
jeder zeit vergegenwärtigen wie fragil
wir alle sind wir haben oft das gefühl
wir sitzen hier fest im sattel und wir
steuern unser leben und es braucht so
nichts das alles umgeworfen ist und so
bleibt dann eben in der tat auch wenn
man vorzeitig arbeitet und sonst sein
leben führt sich eben doch immer dieser
tatsache zu vergegenwärtigen was mich
persönlich am meisten tröstet ist was
das ich verspüren
bei den menschen die mich umgeben die
mir wichtig sind meinen sie
meine familie das ist das was bleibt und
was weitergeht und der rest von mir als
person als körper ist dann vielleicht
zweitrangig was wäre das bei jedem frei
mähne
also bei mir während die liebe und zwar
habe ich dir für mich das gefühl dass
die toten nicht von uns weg sterben
sondern eigentlich sterben sie in uns
hinein was heißt das ja also wir wenn
sie sind nicht weg sondern sie sind in
unserem herzen irgendwann das ist ein
weg das ist ein prozess aber warum
jammern wir denn wenn einer stirbt dann
jammern wäre doch weil wir ihn lieben
gut nicht immer lieben wir uns das ist
auch menschlich aber eigentlich tut das
doch so weh dass man jemanden hergeben
muss den mann so sehr mag und dann ist
er scheinbar weg weil dieser körper eben
nicht mehr funktioniert oder einen
unfall hatte und das was bleibt für mich
ist einfach diese liebe und die kann
auch niemand wegnehmen und das ist im
grunde fast so schön wie mit den würmern
also dieser kreise läuft ja doch
natürlich es ist etwas ganz natürliches
aber wir sollten uns vielleicht um diese
natürlichen prozesse ein bisschen mehr
bemühen und wieder zeit investieren
darüber nachzudenken und sie zu leben
das nehme gerne us-blätter eva schiller
wir sind schon fast am ende der sendung
ganz vielen herzlichen dank dass sie da
waren noch einen grossen applaus
wir haben ich bedanke mich auch ganz
herzlich bei ihnen bei einer runde hier
martin trat stefan eichmüller mark
benecke dass sie hier waren und ganz
herzlichen dank ihnen allen im saal auch
ein publikum für sie dass sie daran
haben herzlichen dank ihnen zu hause ist
es zu schauen hier geht es jetzt gleich
weiter mit dem film schauen auf der deb
eine horrorfilm persiflage dies mit dem
grusel mit dem nicht so ganz ernst sind
sondern mit viel humor
dem grusel auf die schliche geht und das
schlusswort hat pedro lenz müssen
gewächse felix ines doujak vorlegen
wollen bündnerland und der beide treffer
frage papa sachs im rezept jürgen albers
im nebenzimmer betriebene berg papas ist
ja nicht ganz genau
du weißt ja immer ganz genau wie der
berg kreißte die gleiche frage sie
fragen was auf der burg schon langsam
beantworten und oder trotzdem immer
wieder stellt vielleicht zum sich sie
dass das eis immer noch gültig ist
das ist lee nervös die basis herum
vermittelt wie verziertes mal plötzlich
von praktischer ist philosophischer hunt
muss er im tunnel von teamchef 06 events
ausgang hat jedes tunnel warten ausgang
aber wenn es mal klemmt was ist wenn es
krebsgang hat - aber was war dein papa
sag doch was wäre wenn man einfach
vergeben mit dem turnier aus die ganze
zeit im donaumoos kruska tun wird um die
bootstour gemacht hat der völlig
vergessen ausgangs machen paprotta und
der tonight show langfeld xi und zum
gemacht und geburt ist im architektur
gefangen bleiben und man eigentlich
genau wie die uci hat wirklich jedes
tonausgang vertrieben mit bzw
[Musik]
[Applaus]